the Declaration of Independence was
officially adopted by Congress on this
day two hundred and forty-one years ago
to celebrate the fourth of July the New
York Public Library displayed its rare
copy of the Declaration handwritten by
Thomas Jefferson
it features Jefferson's condemnation of
the slave trade but that passage was
dropped in the final version of the
document to appease southern delegates
the manuscript is one of only two
complete copies known to have survived
intact historian Kenneth Davis C Davis
is the best-selling author of don't know
much about history and in the shadow of
Liberty we are pleased to have him back
here at this table good to see you sir I
should be with you good morning and
happy before I have important and stay
to all of you I'm stuck with your an
image of you as Tom Cruise and I have to
get that out of my way so I'm saying
happy fourth date is saying happy
Independence Day
both are appropriate John Adams would
say that we should have said happy July
2nd that was the date on which Congress
actually approved a resolution of
Independence he wrote home to Abigail
this is the day that will go down in
history will celebrate with parades and
pomp and church bells ringing he was
just off by two days it's the 4th and
the adoption of the declaration that
becomes the Mamaroneck I'm surprised at
what little I know about history the
basic things that you learned that
you're kind of surprised took a
different turn George Washington for
instance where was he at the sliding of
the Declaration he did not sign the
Declaration of Independence he was
actually here in New York City of course
Washington had taken over the
Continental Army a year before gone up
to Cambridge first and then the British
left Boston and came down to New York
Washington had the troops here the
Declaration was sent to him he had it
read aloud to the troops on July 9th
they went out then and tore down a
statue of King George the third and
legend has it melted it down into
bullets Hamilton would have been him
with him at the time Washington Hamilton
would have been with Washington at the
time that was then the lead-up to the
Battle of New York which was not a happy
moment for Hamilton or Washington it was
a tremendous defeat for the Continental
Army if we can Arena said there are
things about history you're surprised
that you don't
what about George Washington what don't
we know that the history books haven't
taught us about him well he didn't
chopped down a cherry tree so let's get
rid of that he is a fascinating
character in so many ways I think the
thing that where I always must come back
to because we don't discuss it as what
you mentioned in terms of the
Declaration Washington also was a
slaveholder was one of the largest
slaveholders at the time in fact in 1776
and he was already beginning to wrestle
with that problem this contradiction how
do we fight for liberty yet keep people
in Chains and so that's that's a problem
you mentioned Jefferson condemning
slavery and and B and the southerners
objecting to it but Jefferson also noted
that a great many men of the North
objected because they were making a good
deal of money transporting slaves there
were slaves in every one of the thirteen
colonies Jefferson wrote a condemnation
of slavery in one of the versions that's
right his draft which the the library
has the New York Public Library has a
fair copy he made it a few days
afterwards it includes this long
denunciation of slavery as what he
called the X occur boat commerce again
how could he denounce slavery while
keeping acting that was taken out I can
tell you that like all writers Jefferson
was not happy at being edited by the
Congress days but that in particular was
taken out and it is this great
contradiction on nation conceived in
Liberty was also born in shackles and I
think we still have to balance that out
when we look at these great men and what
they accomplished they did risk life
liberty and and their fortunes their
sacred honor they would have been strung
up if they had been caught but they also
were fighting to preserve and protect
this crime against humanity called
slavery I wish I had learned more about
women in American history Sally Hemings
were learning so much more about her in
recent years who Thomas Jefferson
fathered six children with they just
recently discovered her living quarters
what a WoW moment that was yesterday
seeing the news from Monticello that
they discovered the room in which Sally
Hemings may have lived there's still a
lot of work to be done to ascertain what
exactly went on there of course just a
background Sally Hemings
is 30 years younger than Thomas
Jefferson when and he meets her when
she's 14 essentially she's taking care
of his own daughter she comes to Paris
she's sent as a 14 year old with a
nine-year-old girl on a ship across the
sea it was very different times of
course and that's when he first meets
her Sally Hemings is Jefferson's late
wife's half-sister we always have to
remember that this how close these
connections were this is not an
abstraction this is a human face that's
why I wrote this book in the shadow of
Liberty to put a human face on this
thing we call slavery
what about Betsy Ross so we are we talk
about the American flag and how the
American flag is then changed so her
family says she was the one who sewed
the original Stars and Stripes right is
that true but the legend was that
Washington came in and he got his French
cuffs owned by Betsy Ross she was a
seamstress in Philadelphia but the the
flagged story is pretty much a creation
handed down by the family she did so
flags for Philadelphia are Pennsylvania
state flags for their Navy more
interesting as a man you've probably
never heard of named Francis Hopkinson
one of the 56 signers he actually took
credit for the design of the flag as we
know what the Stars and Stripes he
submitted a bill to Congress asking for
payment for his services he wanted a
quarter cask of the public wine there
was the public while but they turned him
down because he was already on the
payroll they didn't want double dipping
but this is these are the stories behind
the dates and the battles and the
speeches and it is important to remember
that these were real people doing real
things yeah definitely history coming
alive here are these pages thank you so
much Kenneth C Davis for joining us